what's up everybody welcome to LED live
what do you guys think about when you
think about the word paradise find out
on this episode of LED live where am I
[Music]
first off we'd like to thank our patreon
donors without you guys we could not do
this show you make it possible thank you
so much if you'd like to support our
channel click on the link below and find
out how you can become a patreon donor
and get lots of cool perks also if you
didn't know we have DVDs on our website
we have documentaries that are not on
YouTube also they're available on Vimeo
and digital download and for rent we
also have t-shirts if you like t-shirts
or know somebody that does like them
that helps us support our ministry and
you can really wear your witness
good conversation starters to break the
ice on spiritual topics now into
Paradise Hills look at this poster this
was a poster that came out before the
show and it literally says rebel against
perfection this is like once again
Hollywood hammering the idea of
perfection do away with it yeah we don't
want anything to do with perfection it's
interesting because I watched a couple
of like interviews of behind the scenes
cuz I was really trying to figure out
like what all was in the movie and see
if they leak out anything but they were
interviewing the director and they're
just like oh it's such an original
storyline though the film it's probably
the most different film I've seen this
year so far it's a it's sci-fi it's
thriller it's fantasy it's adventure
it's romance it's pretty much everything
I'm just like this is the same joke over
and over there's nothing original about
this it's like the same script the adult
version ugly dolls being for the kids
small food I mean literally if you just
click through the hundreds of videos
that we've made it's the same concept
actually in this documentary called
Gnostic Gospels this available on the
website this was one of the first things
you did right yeah we talked about the
movie 300
maybe you've heard of a movie called The
Matrix The Truman Show all of these have
very similar elements Pleasantville was
another video that we discussed in this
and this formula that you see over and
over and over again this utopian style
paradise-like environment is evil and we
need to get away from that so this
really breaks down a lot of those if you
if you love the matrix I mean well we
literally could have done a video
literally on the whole Matrix series I
probably had a whole series of videos on
it because it was so crazy deep but this
really exposes the Gnosticism and I'm
sure what you're gonna show today has
those elements in it yeah this is very
eye-opening it just kind of breaks down
the template that we see over and over
and over again it gives lots of really
good examples looking at that poster it
said what rebel against perfection
Matthew 5:48 says be perfect even as
your heavenly Father is perfect and this
poster says rebellion against perfection
now lets me know right there as a
Christian right and first first email 15
tells us that rebellion is the sin of
witchcraft and if you look at witchcraft
in the Bible it never says anything good
about it in fact it says all those
people in the Old Testament were to be
put to death and it was pretty immediate
there was no like waiting period as note
you're stoned you're dead no witchcraft
okay same thing on the Star Wars series
I mean it's really even some of the
posters say a rebellion built on hope
yeah and they hammer this idea that the
rebellion is really the good guys the
Republic they are the ones that should
be feared and as evil against but you
know be on the side of rebellion you
look at I think it's the definition of a
rebel I want to say on this for a
dictionary but it doesn't it say like
that it's against an established
government or wrong okay so if you take
the Star Wars series for example you
have two sides you have the rebellion
and you have the Empire and you look at
those just by definitions an empire is
ruled by a single supreme authority
right yeah and then the rebellion is
against an established government or
Rula so it's like it's pretty clear just
even in definitions what's what's going
on and how it's playing out who is whose
mo is that reminding you of could it be
[Music]
exactly yeah like God has this perfect
law perfect government where one day
where all the believers are gonna live
there in perfect peace and harmony
because we know that his laws are
perfect and just and there for us and
theirs but if you're a rebel you're not
gonna fit in there and you're gonna end
up becoming just like Lucifer rebellion
in heaven so obviously being paradise
and rebellion in paradise this goes all
the way back to the Garden of Eden man
yeah look at the garden I mean the whole
the imagery of this movie is all taking
place in a garden I don't know exactly
what the word for Duchess is like what a
definition of a Duchess is they call her
a Duchess I'm not sure but I'm asking
you to be the tiniest bit receptive to
your propaganda so paradise in Luke
23:43 and second Corinthians 12:4 and in
revelation 2:7 these are all
descriptions of heaven and they call it
paradise so there's you know we're not
stretching here paradise is heaven now
watch this trailer
good morning woman where am I
you're in paradise of course what is
this place this is an opportunity
if you could learn your place you have
your best years ahead of you
our family sent us here to shape us in
their image you are in our brave new
world
it's about owning your story who you
truly are
what were helped to change over your
there's always a way to get what you
want I'm getting out of here
[Music]
every night they make us sleep like
we're dead
[Music]
like it says if that girl never existed
first I find you
there's a lot to this movie that I'm not
even gonna try to get into it all but
it's all right there in the trailer like
so much was right there what she hasn't
notice in the trailer it being a place
of paradise they flash the words that
purity and they were supposed to be made
or sent there to be made into their
father's and yeah and that the that the
you know at first it's like oh oh you're
in paradise and it's this really nice
thing but by the end of the trailer they
show you that there's really something
evil behind the people that are keeping
you there yeah yeah so it and it's all
about control in case you didn't catch
it the words that came on the screen
said where's serenity which is peace
we're purity help you to begin again
that's biblical but they're making it
like this is a bad thing this is
something to run from I'm getting out of
here you know interesting note that they
said they flash their words at you be
true to yourself I mean like it's always
gonna stem back to you whatever you want
to do is the slogan right what do you
notice about these girls right here all
dressed in white yeah so there was an
article that was talking about them on
the set and and they they're talking
about but as the days pass by its
students become increasingly suspicious
that something more sinister lurks
behind the cheery exterior of canopy
beds blooming gardens and dazzling white
uniforms think about the Garden of Eden
blooming Gardens dazzling white uniforms
I'm not sure that Adam and Eve were
wearing you know uniforms but they were
dressed in a white light rain revelation
3/4 says thou has a few names even in
sardis which have not defiled their
garments and they shall walk with me in
white for they are worthy so when you
look at this picture you look at this
Paradise Hills I mean that's the
description of heaven all these people
in white everything seems to be perfect
the garden is beautiful and everybody's
following these rules but she's like I'm
out of here she does not want to be
there so here's another another
alternative poster and real small right
here
rebels rain so back to what Keith said
first name at 15:23 for rebellion is as
the sin of witchcraft I mean right here
you see the duality Paradise Hills
rebels rain it's weird how they just
made it so small and subliminal like
that all these people they go to this
reform thing because they're not doing
something they're supposed to do her
thing is she doesn't want to marry who
her parents wanted to marry ever heard
that again yeah right how many cartoons
follow that by following my feelings I
wound up doing the right thing I guess I
learned that my duty is to my heart
Pocahontas same story marry kocoum
father I think my dream is pointing me
down another path this is the right path
for you movies are supposed to be
something you relate to I don't know why
we keep seeing this theme of where they
call that when you're forth on a forced
marriage like that
Oh arranged yeah why don't we keep
seeing this arranged marriage does
anyone really face that in America it
just seems like an odd thing to throw in
a movie when you're supposed to be
identifying it when really the only
thing that really makes us identify with
that is the biblical narrative of we're
supposed to be married to Christ he's
coming back for his bride she doesn't
want to marry the prince who's in this
you know she's going through this
rehabilitation or whatever it is reform
school to become perfect to marry this
guy she wants to break loose on the
cover of the movie you see here there's
two guys one of them is the guy she's
supposed to marry and one of them's this
other guy these are their names Marcus
and Sun interesting it's not just like
he is a Sun or the Sun like it's his
name's Don capital s Sun you look at the
Internet Movie Database I actually saw
clips where they said
name their like son they it's not like
his parents they're saying son wants to
marry you or whatever she's supposed to
be married off to this upper name son
we are not sure she's okay with this so
you're gonna play some tricks to
convince her you know they try to paint
her as as defiant his name the son with
capital S and this guy's name is Marcus
and when you look at the picture of
Marcus you know his his garments are all
wrinkled now that that is interesting
that he like you know when they show you
something like this in the frame you
have to think like how many how many
points checkpoints basically those
wardrobes have gone through for them to
get to the place where it's actually in
a picture like this I mean there's
people that are steaming all the
garments they're putting them on they're
hung they're kept by the Wardrobe so for
him to have a wrinkled garment means
that was extremely purposeful yeah there
were nobody else in the frame actually
has a wrinkled garment yeah there'd be a
very angry director yeah that he's like
unkept notice how the son has his hair
all nice and perfectly done and so this
guy's got his hair all messy like he's
like already there in the rebel type
yeah
the son and Marcus so Marcus according
to Wikipedia it's a it's a Roman god
it's it's Mars and Mars is God of War
exactly the God of War Roman pagan
website here says Mars is the god of
violence war valor and virility suitable
offerings to Mars include spelt wheat
meat and wine and who does that sound
like the God of War she falls in love
with Mars the God of War Marcus here you
see them embracing she doesn't want to
marry son but I'm not marrying him I
told her that the prince in white who
she's having to go through this reform
school just even you know
be convinced to Miriam let me ask you
this why do you think rebellion is
equated to witchcraft
what exactly is witchcraft well when
that comes from in this story in Samuel
if you kind of read that whole account
what was happening was Saul was going to
war with the Philistines and Samuel had
told Saul to destroy everybody that he
was going to war with don't take any of
the animals don't take any of the of the
people alive don't leave any of the
Kings you need just you need to
literally kill everybody because it was
like an infectious people that basically
Israel was struggling with and so when
Saul went to go destroy them he actually
kept some of the best for himself he
kept some of the animals he didn't
destroy the king and so when Samuel came
back he was like what is this believing
that I hear in the sound of Lambs and
sound of cattle why didn't you do what
God told you to do and he was like oh I
did I did exactly what God told me to do
and salmon was like no you didn't do
what God told you to do because I told
you to destroy everything and you kept
these ones
so even Saul was to just like literally
deceiving himself thinking that he had
done what God had asked to do but he
didn't he didn't do what he did to do so
that's when Samuel made the reference
saying that listen rebellion is as a sin
of witchcraft it blinds you from the
truth I think if we look at that verse
in 1st Samuel 15:23 they're not reading
all of it if we read all of it I think
we get a bit of a better picture such as
rebellion is the sin of witchcraft and
stubbornness is as iniquity and idolatry
then it continues it says because you
have rejected the word of the Lord
he has also rejected you from being king
so this all together is like wrapped up
in this idea that rebellion is like
witchcraft it's it's like I don't and
yeah you have stubbornness with mixed in
there which is like iniquity which is
sin which is I you know which is
idolatry and then you have rejecting the
word of the Lord
right as ultimately what he did is he
No God said one thing I'm gonna do
something else it's the same problem
that we've had since the very beginning
right Cain in the Garden of Eden they
chose to do something different than
what God said in the in heaven when
Satan deceived you know so many angels
Satan said in his heart you know I am
going to do something different than
what God said and that's gotten us in
trouble for a long long time every time
every time I mean there's not one time
that we're like I did it my way God and
it was better than what you had for me I
mean you brought up a good point Cain as
well
God said worship in this way Cain
decides no I'm gonna worship in my own
way I'm still trying to worship God I'm
still trying to do it in my own like my
own way that I see fit but it wasn't in
the design that God wanted to see and
that was a rebellious spirit and it came
about so yeah you see tons of those
examples so this was a just a still shot
from she's the the director of the movie
she never went to film school she this
was her first movie actually and like
all these huge name actresses and stuff
in it and she only had one short film
before this I just think it's
interesting that she's wearing like an
all-seeing eye earring and her her
outfit is like palm-reading and
astrology all over it so you know people
ask us all the time like do these people
just sit in a smoke room and be like oh
how can we deceive all the Christians
and we don't think that's the case we
think they're being inspired influenced
by Satan one way or another a lot of
these celebrities will tell you I
couldn't affected that part dens I was
like that wasn't me I couldn't acted
that partly what I did was got on my
knees
and sort of communicated with the
spirits and when I came out I was in
charge powerful soon powerful seen it
would I couldn't have acted that you
know I and you know hear that people say
Beyonce says I lifted my hands and that
was the first time I felt something come
into me right before I performed I
raised my hands up and it was kind of
the first time I felt something else
come into me
and I knew that was gonna be my
coming-out night these actresses actors
singers they all say like I have a demon
in me my man is a crazy boy who lives in
me I asked him to leave but he can't
he's here for a reason
you know some kind of alternate
personality method acting all that so we
believe that these people are being
inspired and a lot of like the lady who
wrote Harry Potter she got the she got
the script from a dream she had who gave
her that dream right it's all about
witchcraft Twilight from a dream you
know James Cameron getting avatar from a
dream totally makes sense cuz it's a
Satan's message so they're praying to
him for guidance influence in the same
way that before we present Scripture we
pray for the Holy Spirit to guide us
that's right it's really not that hard
to to understand that's right that's
right yeah and like I said it's just
ironic that people are like wow what a
what a revolutionary film like something
so original yet we see it's the same
exact thing over and over
so the first movie that she did was
called disco inferno as a short that she
made in 2015 I think the whole movie is
only like 14 minutes long but this is a
screen cap from this movie that she did
all these people are wearing goat heads
and cloaks and I mean looks like
something really occult yeah
those from doing that to all of a sudden
making this like major she she was asked
like where inspiration came from she
said she her parents were obsessed with
sci-fi movies her mom's favorite movie
metropolis of course yeah big time and
she is all into manga and stuff like
that and like you saw she's wearing a
cult symbols all over her and here's
just we'll just watch the trailer for
this thing
[Music]
you can try to make him walk beside you
you can say the door is open
if you grab him woe betide you because
like a butterfly upon an a priori
quickly taking fright if I can catch him
I will try in an interesting is like
this has one like if you notice I get
got all these awards so my Springs Film
Festival at all these different villas
is like really like Matt's like what did
it win is some crazy story of somebody
like literally walking around and fire
Scottie Scottie
that is art oh my it's like if you if
you do something borderline satanic
occult it's near everybody's like it but
if you do something about Jesus it's
like oh yeah what are you doing what are
you doing stop forcing your beliefs down
my throat wait a minute every movie you
put out is about rebelling against
perfection and running away from
paradise like why do people not look at
that and say stop pushing your anti
Christian beliefs down my throat I'm
trying to just live my life any
interesting thing to do is it's like
what if what if we had a a society that
was literally just like you know be kind
to those that hate you do good to those
that are you know mean to you like be
loving towards people what if that was
like the greatest thing that we were
promoting out there and like those are
the things that would win it or Awards
like how much differently would society
be I just don't see how society is okay
with things that encourage rebellion and
you know it's a lot of it's in the way
it's done though see God's method in the
all throughout history has not been
force right it's been like as he as it
was with Elijah you know that's that
still small voice right but as you go
through to progress throughout time
Satan's taking this tactic of well I
know how I'm gonna influence people I'm
gonna do it subtly and then when the
Christians come around and say something
about it I'm gonna call it force right
so he's putting his own methods on them
you know and same and and decrying them
no you guys you guys are using this this
hate its force here you're trying to
cram it down everybody's throat you know
which is exactly what he does so he's
done a very clever job of you know
slightly trying to shut people down and
also influence other people and I think
that's where God tells Satan I'm gonna
lay you out before Kings I'm gonna show
the world who you your true character is
where this rebellion leads they will be
able to make a choice whether you know
and and and at the very end that's where
in you know no tongue
literally says you know God we're
fighting against you every tongue mouth
and says God you are right
Satan you were wrong yeah well speaking
about decisions why you guys think
people are so against the concept of
perfection I think I think like like
it's a two-edged sword almost almost in
the same way that that we hear so much
about like fundamental extra extremists
right so all of a sudden you hear these
two concepts constantly put out in the
media it's like oh there's always these
fundamental extremists and they're gonna
like walk into your store and blow you
up with a bomb strapped to them or
whatever like this right when really if
you get to the core of what
fundamentalism is following the Bible
right and and because they're associated
with those those those character traits
then everybody looks the whole thing as
evil like well fundamental
fundamentalism must be evil I think the
same thing is happening here there are a
group of people that run around and say
you must be perfect and and you know and
and there's this like sort of extremist
version of that and so then everybody
attributes negative feelings towards
that when really the Bible has a lot to
say about us being perfect so it's like
a misunderstanding of what perfection is
yeah it's like would agree with that you
know
if for instance in the fashion industry
or magazines whatever the case
perfection would be you know polished
and perfect symmetry and all these
things when in reality that's not that's
not perfection that's not real at all so
in the view of other areas that
perfection falls into it yeah people
have just this wrong warped twisted view
of what it actually is I was also gonna
bring up Romans 8:7 says because the
carnal mind is at enmity with God or
against God or you know says for is not
subject to the law of God neither indeed
can it be so our carnal nature rejects
all things god it just does that's
that's that's like inbred into our DNA
if you will since the fall so if it's
godly our carnal nature says no I don't
have anything to do with it you know so
if it's if it's perfect if it's loving
if it's kind any of that we're just no
because we're all about me we're all
about self as carnal human beings first
John two 15 through 17 tells us though
love not the world neither the things in
the world If any man loves the world the
love of the father is not in him and it
says for all that is in the world the
lust of the flesh the lust of the eyes
and the pride of life which these three
things it's it's like categorically
defining what our problem is with sin
right is not of the Father but is of the
world and the world passes away and the
lust thereof but he that does the will
of God abides forever right so we have
to he on the will of God right those
that do the will of God II what God is
asking you to do not rebelling against
what God is asking us to do yeah I was
gonna say like correct me if I'm wrong
because we're all trying to learn this
stuff but I would think that the
biblical definition of perfect is what
desiring to do God's will we're gonna
fail we're carnal and we're you know
we're flawed but if you desire to do his
will and in those occasions that you
fall we have an advocate with the father
we pray for forgiveness we receive that
forgiveness repent turn from it get back
on the straight and narrow
but just a blatant rebellion like I see
this law and I don't like it so I'm
gonna do what I want to do that's
iniquity lawlessness that's rebellion
and and that's where you know Jesus says
depart from me I never knew you you who
work lawlessness but I think those who
love God and submit to him and desire to
follow his will they bring up an
interesting point because the Bible
talks about this in Psalm 40 verse 8 it
says I delight to do thy will right so
this is David right he's I've want to do
your will God and then he says something
really interesting
he says yay thy law is within my heart
so he even knows how to do God's will
right it's not ambiguous and it's not
whatever I think it is right God has
already defined what it is what his will
is right he says it's my law right these
are the things that I've asked you to do
these are the things that I want you to
do I'm not I'm not making you guess
right I've clearly defined it so you
know what it is you know what the
expectation is because eventually when
God comes back and he says to everybody
look those of you those of you who have
sinned you're going to everlasting
darkness they have to know well how did
I sin yeah right that has to be defined
somewhere and then those that he said
okay depart from me you workers of
iniquity right what is iniquity right
right going all the way back to that
beginning verse with saying 15 yeah it's
it's basically sin now there's there's
probably fine distinctions theologically
between sin transgression and iniquity
that is basically sin and we already
know the Bible says we're what is is a
first John 3:4 right it says
transgression of sin is transgression
now there's also verse you might know
what it is where it says to no good and
to not do it to him it is sin I think
that's in James right so when you know
what the Ten Commandments say and you
write well I know what it says but I'm
gonna do it that's a little different
than just stumbling I mean you might be
in a weak moment and fall into lust and
be like Oh what happened but to be like
yeah I'm gonna meet that chick in an
hour I mean that's a little different
yeah I think the pushback comes because
of the difficulty level
it's hard to be perfect especially when
we're trying to achieve that on our own
and but you can't do it on your own
that's the whole point because I could
you wouldn't need Jesus ever exactly and
with with that difficulty level comes
frustration and then frustration leads
to the rebellion and I think in order to
achieve perfection submission needs to
be attached to that and then that
submission leads to the acceptance of
Jesus Christ which then leads to
perfection so mm-hmm
having that missing link really really
creates the split just having that link
creates that destruction it is is Jesus
through and through because you know God
says that he is the author and finisher
of our faith right he's the one that
starts it he's the one that finishes it
you know we we can't do this thing that
he's that he's asked us to do you know
just like Israel old all that you've
asked us to do we will do right is
sitting at the the foot of Mount Sinai
what is list of the 10 commandments and
then what do you see you next and the
storyline it's like no they didn't do it
they completely failed right they went
exactly the opposite way but it's God
through and through saying you know I'm
the one that's gonna make the Covenant I
am the one that's gonna keep the
covenant because you guys aren't able to
keep it you can't do it in Ezekiel 36 it
says I will cause you to keep my
judgments and my statutes and you will
do that and you will do yeah it's not us
that's doing it it's good that's doing
it through us sure Paul has that
experience to Romans 8 and 9 saying that
I'm not able to keep the law it's the
Christ spirit in me that allows me to do
it that's right yeah yeah and it if you
if we think about it just like from a
logical standpoint
God is not asking us he would not ask he
would not come here to die to eradicate
sin and then ask us to live sinful lives
right no he would come and say no follow
me right I've lived a life that was
perfectly free from sin now follow me
now you're not gonna be able to do that
but I'm gonna help you but he's not
calling us to say add don't worry about
that you know
big deal I mean I died for it but you
know because if it wasn't a big deal
again then why would Jesus have to die
for it right if it was just something
yeah well we can just get rid of that we
can just erase that God thought it was
so important that there was no other way
that his son had to die like that's the
consequence of what sin is the wages of
sin is death it's some eternal law from
forever that we don't even understand
the full implications oh right so
anytime there would have been sin the
wages of sin would have been death and
so Christ came in and did that for us
and and we can be grateful that you know
we can have freedom in Christ but he but
he wouldn't continue now to say oh you
know don't worry about it just sin
whatever right and he wants to give us a
gift have you turned a life he wants
everyone he's not willing that any
should perish but all that come to reap
enter it's in you know which means it's
not sowing from sin he's not saying I
want to just give it everybody all the
molesters all the pedophiles you get
eternal life to live in the kingdom I'm
glad that we're gonna live in a kingdom
free of that pain and misery you know
it's really a act of mercy towards those
people because you know imagine a thief
living in heaven and he can still be
tortured a theist living with the God
that he hated and all the people he
mocked every day like it's almost like
looking at this paradise Hills is like
almost kind of looking at through the
eyes of a sinful person trying to be in
heaven
I mean it's like yeah it would seem like
it was torture to them and they would be
desirous of trying to rebel against that
type of system so it's almost like this
is kind of telling you the truth but
from their perspective I think miss
telling the truth because they always
make the leader of the perfect world
some terrible dictator you know
tyrannical you know the ugly dolls Lou
this chick is this Duchess or whatever
yeah we just see that over and over so
this film is teaching this idea about
you know perfection and rebelling
against perfection and all that and not
yet idea of course we know comes from
Satan because that's what he didn't have
an he rebelled
[Music]
the spirits of rebellion and also
it's interesting what it says in a m-19
though it says what do you imagine
against the Lord says he will make an
utter end affliction shall not rise the
second time well what is affliction you
look at this in the Strong's Concordance
and it talks about that this is
adversity right where who who is the
adversary if it is right it's Satan
right so we know what this is talking
about affliction all of that comes from
Satan none of that's gonna be in heaven
it won't rise up a second time so
there's no sin in heaven which is
another evidence to me that says we're
not here for Christ to deliver us from
sin and then him to just say you know I
live your life whatever you want to do
mmm you know because that again is not
gonna be in heaven we've seen that in
one of our when uh one of our other
videos recently I see this paradigm more
and more of what was it like before sin
what is it like after sin
well this block in between time we
should be striving to do the same yeah
through through Christ self because
that's the only way we can do it is is
is by the blood of Jesus but we're not
here to be rebelling and and living
lives of you know it's just whatever
yeah I see this life as the experience
of doing it our own way you know you
tell the kid don't touch the electrical
a lot outlet you're gonna get up and
they doubt you and they do it they
experience the shock they'll never do it
again
so God told the entire universe these
are my laws Satan says I'm gonna do it
my way God says all right you'll see
what happens if you do it your way and
we're all reaping the consequences of
going against God's law so that you know
Satan had that chance to doubt because
he never saw it the other way he never
saw what happens if I try it my way see
the results yeah we're gonna get to rise
up and be in this perfect world and if
anyone had a doubt be like mmm let's
watch the Earth's history again
you know drug abuse prostitution all
this terrible things World War three
when you're after so much time in heaven
you know if if people just won't want to
look at that you know I mean like
probably not yeah I don't want to I
don't want to remember what that like
you know crazy place was down there yeah
there's no more pain no more suffering
no more tears none of that so in my mind
it's like once once once you've been
past the review you know cuz Paul talks
about don't you know you leavin judge
angels once you get past that review
period you're like okay yeah God was
just God was faithful everything that he
did and recorded in every decision that
he made you know you are you are true
and Justin holy God after that I see
there's any need yeah you know it was
just a metaphor saying yo you could look
back at history
I don't think we'll all remember the
experience and be like no I'm not gonna
do that
been there done that is everybody yeah
all right that was a short episode you
guys ought to get this DVD called
Gnostic Gospels it's very informative
and only $10 we hope you guys enjoyed
the show if you click below you can find
some t-shirts if you order right now the
first 20 people will get 10% off of your
t-shirt and we also got DVDs check this
one out the Gnostic Gospels it really
lays a good foundation of all this
Gnosticism that we see the same template
over and over and over
there's nothing original about these
movies it's the same thing repackaged
over and over again and frankly I'm
getting tired of me how about you thanks
guys we hope you enjoyed the show god
bless come back
[Music]